what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so with Mondays including our Marvel
what if story what do I do here is I
want to cover the story of The
Incredible Hulk killing all the
superheroes and becoming a Herald of
Galactus this is kind of like the worst
case scenario for Earth and it's
actually a lot more complicated than it
seems in terms of all the stuff that
happens meaning it's not like a linear
series of events there's all kinds of
crazy stuff that goes on in the story
it's one of the reasons why I love it so
much but this story comes directly out
of the world war hulk storyline now for
those of you guys don't know and I know
there's a lot of people out there that
do but for those of you guys who don't
know when it came to the world war Hawks
story this was basically just a way to
remove the Incredible Hulk from the
Marvel landscape prior to civil war and
then bring him back and so what Marvel
did is they basically had a group called
the Illuminati Charles Xavier Black Bolt
of the Inhumans thing with a submariner
Doctor Strange they had a group come to
the decision that the Incredible Hulk
was just too unpredictable and violent
to remain on earth and ended up sending
him into space the problem was he ended
up travelling through a through a
wormhole more or less ended up on the
wrong side of the galaxy and landed on a
place called Sekar which led into the
Planet Hulk event whereby he basically
rallied together a whole bunch of
revolutionary forces and was able to
topple the existing king the issue with
this was that while those people who
looked to the Incredible Hulk as the
savior were in the midst of building a
monument the ship that he was sent on by
the Illuminati was detonated
accidentally and set off a thermal
nuclear blast and in doing so he
basically killed the incredible Hulk's
new wife their unborn child or I guess
their newborn child and you know
basically everybody that the Hulk knew
on the New Kingdom that he had settled
for himself and so because of this he
returned back to earth with what he
called his warbound his pact of people
that he had a come to view as allies
during his time as a gladiator during
the Planet Hulk storyline and he
basically cut a swath through the
superhero community now what this does
is this shows us an alternate situation
because this brings in the events of
secret invasion now secret invasion was
another half
the Marvel storyline that was a series
of events whereby marvel established
that these scrolls who had the ability
to shape-shift had previously had their
planet destroyed by by Galactus and they
had looked to earth as a new home for
themselves in a manifest destiny kind of
situation and the result was that they
had begun the process of replacing the
various occupants human and superhero
alike on earth with Skrull replicants
the issue with this was that during this
part of the story of world war hulk the
scroll Queen is basically Spider Woman
Jessica drew and so because of this
she's still on earth and these Scrolls
are effectively just waiting out in
space for her to give the signal for
them to all show up and and invade the
planet Earth and basically kill off all
the superheroes but what happens here is
that unlike the original world war hulk
event with Reed Richards
creating these satellites that would
basically attack the Incredible Hulk and
destroy him because of the fact that the
battle is going so badly because Bruce
Banner is literally just tearing all the
superheroes apart piece by piece
it's really like a last-ditch effort
it's really just you know just wipe
everything out just you know this is a
scorched earth kind of policy and so
what happens is that aslha at the
request of Reed Richards Tony Stark
launches the satellites and annihilates
everybody and so the most powerful
superheroes who are going against Bruce
Banner are all annihilated in this
destruction or in this Ennis conflict
and so what we do is we actually jump
forward by a few months in the sense
that V Bishop with the Queen having been
killed among all these heroes her a
second-in-command her Bishop who's kind
of like this religious leader in the
Skrull Empire takes control of the
scroll fleet and begins invading the
planet Earth and so what we do is we
switch to you what what seems to be a
few months and we end up joining with a
recreated version of the vision and the
vision shows up and discovers that Bruce
Banner is basically digging graves for
everyone who died in New York whether
they were human whether they were
superhero he's in the middle of building
all this now of course Bruce Banner
can't really survive the high level of
radiation here which is one of the other
reasons why those survivors who weren't
obliterated by the blast we're almost
immediately killed off by the radiation
because it was so potent but he finds a
Bruce banners here and he basically gets
talking with him right he's like hey
look man you know we need you like we
basically need you here now Bruce Banner
doesn't want to have anything to do with
this he says you know yes I could
survive them I hope
but I'm basically dying you know and
this is Bruce Banner just kind of coming
to terms with the destruction that he's
that he's experienced over the course of
his life all the destruction that he's
basically created and so it's him paying
pendens so it's very similar to the
Incredible Hulk last man on earth
storyline that we have previously
covered but what the vision says is look
man like this was not the end like these
superheroes this was in the end while
you've been here in isolation in New
York you know the scrolls invaded earth
and they almost immediately killed off
the x-men whatever superheroes were left
were second-tier at best Wolverine it
was removed from the planet Earth
because his healing factor made him
immortal so the only way to basically
keep him from killing off the scrolls in
their entirety was to just take them
away from Earth so they you know so they
don't have to worry about him here and
the result is that there's only like a
handful of us left there's almost nobody
left alive
we have hate a hate pain we have Janet
Van Dyne we have a couple others here
and their cannonball Sam Guthrie but
they're really just scavenger survivors
the ones who have been trying to make it
day by day and we're rallying them to
our cause so this is kind of the cool
thing is because he says the over Janet
Van Dyne is the one that brought them
all together Janet Van Dyne was the
person that said look we need leadership
here now what most likely happened this
is kind of what we're left to figure out
on our own devices anyway what most
likely happened behind the scenes was
that hank pym really probably does had
like a crisis of conscience that's not
new for his character hey pam has
emotional breakdowns all the time he has
emotional breakdowns with regards to his
personalities he has most of what
multiple breakdowns with regards to you
know whether or not the Super Bowl is
going the way that he wants to - he has
emotional breakdowns for everything it's
insane and so because of this Janet Van
Dyne probably stepped up and really took
the reins and so what happens is we
basically transition to a base in the
and trionic something is what is called
Andrea Dax and it's basically a section
of the world where by some heroes or
some uh some survivors from humans are
trying to take refuge whether they're
being tracked down systematically by the
scrolls and so while hank pym while Sam
gonna do what they can to rescue these
people they're suddenly met by the
arrival of Bruce Banner The Incredible
Hulk now what's also cool about this is
that Bucky Barnes is alive now this is
during the time when Bucky Barnes at
least it seemed as though he was
underground and so it you know for some
reason or another obviously probably the
conflict with the Incredible Hulk
brought him back but whatever the case
may be here he's also one of the
military guys
running the show and we would expect
that with with with Bucky Barnes if
Janet Van Dyne is the one who's in
charge of everything she'd have to have
generals people who would basically go
out and overwatch field missions and
because Bucky Barnes spent so much time
fighting alongside Captain America it
makes perfect sense that he would be one
of the people who would oversee this
conflict but when the Incredible Hulk
arrives Bucky Barnes initially finds it
a little strange because when they get
back to the to an abandoned shield
bunker
most likely having belonged to Nick Fury
and you know operating as a new base of
the Avengers when they get back there
you know Bucky Barnes initially says
this is gonna be strange and the reason
is because everybody doesn't like the
Hulk like a lot of people just hate him
because he was the one that led to this
in the first place beyond the incredible
hoax rampage on a planet Earth the fact
that he cut a swath through so many
different superheroes basically set up
the stage for the scrolls to take
advantage of a fractured earth and in
doing so conquer it and so what happens
is the Incredible Hulk actually
turncoats and says hey look guys you
know I'm here to try to save things I'm
here to fix things you know because of
all destruction the destruction that
I've wrought because while the conflict
that I've created I'm here to try to try
to atone for that and make up for my
past mistakes and so alongside you know
dagger alongside you know Bucky Barnes a
whole horde of superheroes they
literally just start tearing through the
scrolls everywhere I mean they just
start conquering you know conquering US
cities you know they start conquering
outposts they start freeing all these
different people and so when it when it
gets to the point where by the scrolls
are starting to realize that the
Incredible Hulk is working against them
and that with his unbridled strength is
really nothing they can do to stop him
the scroll Bishop says it's time to
enact our spy he says we have a spy
among the ranks of these superheroes and
it's time to bring them out now one of
his one of his generals says well why
did you wait this long you know why did
you wait so long like we've lost
hundreds of people why did you wait
until just now to enact this fine and to
bring them down and this is actually
really really smart the Bishop says
because I wanted all the heroes on one
spot and that's that's the smart thing
because you know the heroes were either
in camps or they were hiding whatever
the case may have been not all of them
were gathered together as part of the
part of the New Avengers as the Bishop
said look the Incredible Hulk is a is a
force of nature
if he allies himself with the event
his strength will give other people
strength and as a result they'll come
out of hiding
though rally under the umbrella of his
capabilities and they'll literally steal
create their own on their own team and
the launch of war against us and so he
says when they do that then that will be
when all the heroes come out and that's
when we strike and so what we learned is
that the Skrull replicant that's been a
part of the Avengers this entire time
was Janet Van Dyne and Janet Van Dyne
had been put there as that scroll
replacement since the beginning of the
conflict since you know almost
immediately after you know the The
Incredible Hulk I guess immediately
after the destruction of Tony Stark when
it came to New York City and so as a
result she says the scrolls had
basically analyzed the genome of a Hank
Pym and they found that he was
effectively unstable in terms of his
molecular structure because of the Pym
particles and so she said what they
could do is they could basically turn
him into a genetic bomb they could
effectively detonate him on the
molecular level and they could let off a
massive wave of destruction and that's
exactly what happens with all the heroes
being there in one place they quite
literally just detonate Hank Pym and in
doing so it's this massive you know I
guess what would amount to a nuclear
explosion and it annihilates every
single hero who's there and so in effect
the Incredible Hulk is the last man on
earth right now I mean all the humans
who were rallied in the bunker of the
New Avengers are dead you know all those
existing humans are gone all the
superheroes that remained on earth that
were in this bunker are gone and so
because of this the Incredible Hulk just
wants to see the earth destroyed and so
what happens is the Incredible Hulk
recalls an instance where by when he was
on the defenders alongside Silver Surfer
and Doctor Strange he recalls that they
were informed by Reed Richards that
there is a homing device a beacon in a
pocket of the negative zone some little
small aspect of the negative zone it can
be accessed using you know whatever
portals it was that existed in what was
left of the Baxter building and The
Incredible Hulk could access this beacon
and use it to call the Silver Surfer and
so Silver Surfer arrives here and when
he does the Incredible Hulk says wipe
out the earth call Galactus and have
them consume the earth now this is crazy
because we've never really seen an
instance where a superhero says we want
Galactus to wipe out the earth of course
and again a lot of that's because the
superheroes don't want their earth
destroyed but even in a lot of like the
post-apocalyptic what-if scenarios for
example be Incredible Hulk being the
last man on earth when all
the population of heroes and humans are
wiped out in a global nuclear war
you know surely this was a scenario he
could have called and he could have just
had the Hat you know Galactus consume
the earth and destroy him but of course
that story needed to take a different
tone and it was written at a different
point in time - so it may just be that
you know for whatever reason Reed
Richards never told them about this
homing beacon that would bring Galactus
in but the only time we've ever really
seen an instance where something like
this has happened was during Jonathan
Hickman's Fantastic Four when you know
Reed Richards realized that there was
going to be a massive conflict of the
planet Earth and summoned Galactus to
fight on his behalf against the mad
Celestials that was really the only time
we've ever really seen that happen and
so the acquittal Hulk here is is just
unbridled rage and so Silver Surfer says
okay fine because right now the
Incredible Hulk will kill him if the
Silver Surfer doesn't do it The
Incredible Hulk will kill him and that's
entirely possible
the Hulkster durability his strength
makes them you know well beyond the
Silver Surfer when it comes to just
sheer force now the Silver Surfer can do
all kinds of crazy things to you we
could probably break down the Hulk on
the on a molecular level you know he
could wipe him out of existence he could
do a lot of different things but when it
comes to this moment right now with the
Incredible Hulk hands around the silver
surfers neck he would kill him he would
literally just just kill him on the spot
so the Silver Surfer says okay fine if
you want your earth destroyed I'll
destroy it all have Galactus destroy
you're the last human here so you're
really the only one that's in a fit
place to judge what happens and so the
silver surfer says not only will I bring
Galactus here and having consumed the
earth I'm leaving I'm not gonna be a
Herald of Galactus this is the last
straw and so the Silver Surfer basically
takes off now of course we follow up
with this with Galactus arriving on
earth with his machine and basically
destroying the earth which is kind of
ironic because Galactus destroying the
the scroll homeworld is the reason why
the scrolls showed up on earth in the
first place and so is really just
history repeating itself but following
the destruction of this earth the
destruction of the superheroes all of
which was led to by the actions of the
Incredible Hulk we end up having him met
with Galactus and Galactus says look my
Herald is gone I have no one here to
fight on my behalf I have no one here to
find these you know fine planners for me
to consume I am going to make you my new
Herald I'm going to make you the guy who
is going to be the one that goes out and
finds these planets for me now the
problem with the Incredible Hulk is that
for him the heat wanted he wanted to die
he didn't want to you know he wanted the
earth destroyed because he wanted to be
destroyed with it for him his actions
his violence his conflict
destruction had led to the deaths of all
the superheroes that he had ever known
it led to the death of all of humanity
and so for him he wanted an end to the
whole damn thing he one of the scrolls
destroyed because they killed
superheroes and they took over the earth
and then he wanted to die because he was
the source of all the the suffering that
he had ever experienced in his life but
Galactus says no not only that I'm not
going to make you live a new life
remembering everything that had happened
I'm going to make you forget I'm gonna
wipe your memory of everything that had
ever happened this is going to be a
clean slate and you were gonna go
forward as my Herald in the universe
with no realization of who you were
before this moment and that's exactly
what happens The Incredible Hulk
becomes the Herald of Galactus and
presumably goes about the world you know
doing whatever is it heed are growing
about the universe or whatever is he
does as far as I know there's no
follow-up series to this this is just
this is it which if there was a
follow-up series and if there is
somebody post a comment let me know
because I want to make videos on that I
want to make videos on the Incredible
Hulk as a Herald of Galactus that would
be so beasts like post a comment like if
you guys would want to see something
like that post a comment if it exists
I'll make a video on you know the first
story arc or something like that but
yeah so anyway that's a story The
Incredible book becoming a heirloom
Galactus he like his entire life led to
the destruction of all the superheroes
not to mention his violence and rage and
with everything dead with all humans and
all superheroes dead Galactus just makes
it his Herald so if you guys are new
here to college explained make sure you
guys hit the subscribe button if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and leave a comment down below
and let me know what you guys think and
I will catch you all in it peace